thank you
hi I am Penny Adler and my Gratz title
is on the on the screen it's making
goat's milk soap business sustainable by
implementing standard manufacturing and
testing protocols and just to kind of
talk about it I am a small farmer by
Watertown South Dakota we raise goats
and I make soap one of the cool things
though that we're doing is we're doing a
new product and I
um
see if I can show you but this is the
cream soap it's soap in a jar so it's
not bar soap it's just something totally
different and it's pretty unique there
are very few people that do it
so what's unique about it is the lather
and you can play with this lather and
it'll go and go and go so I just kind of
want to show you that lather because
that's part of the uniqueness of the
product
the other part of the product though
that I'll show you and I'm making a mess
here is that um this is my batch and you
can see it should be nice and brown and
it should not have this so I had a
failed batch and so that's kind of how
this got going for the grant was because
I love my product I don't love failures
and then the other part of it is is I
always want to be natural so our tagline
is wholesome living in a colorful world
we make colorful soaps but we also like
wholesome soaps so the question was is
can I make cream soaps 100 natural or or
what is what do I need to do to make it
safe for my customers
so that was kind of the impetus for the
grant
um in the end I wanted a consistent safe
product
I wanted to be selling financially lower
my costs or know my costs lower my costs
and then also because I'm excited about
doing this I wanted to be able to Market
that hey when you buy from me you know
what you're getting a consistent safe
product
thank you our goals are these were the
four product goals from our grant
I'm going to today talk to you about the
first one create manufacturing and
testing protocols if you like what you
hear I would love to talk about the
other ones so um you can always invite
me back and I would love to talk about
preservatives and also product testing
so the first thing I want to talk about
is um everything that I do
is soap almost everything
so but I'm going to tell you that
everything I developed in this is based
on
cosmetics
so the question is for you is SOPA
cosmetic and the answer is sometimes
so if you want your soap to be soap you
have to have a consists of an Alkali of
salt of fatty acids and that's no
problem as soon as you mix lye and oils
you you meet that definition so
everybody meets that definition usually
and the product must be labeled sold and
represented solely as soap so that means
if you sell something that cleans
you are selling soap and the Cosmetics
don't apply to you
however sometimes your soap is a
cosmetic so I do not sell soap
I sell a product that will make your
skin feel good after you use it it makes
your skin feel soft it feels
moisturizing
I make the process of making soap the
interaction between the lies and the
oils creates glycerin glycerin is a
humectren it attracts moisture out of
the air to your skin and doesn't that
sound moisturizing as soon as I say any
of those things I'm a cosmetic
so because of that everything I've
developed in this presentation or in my
own practices is based on I am a
cosmetic
I am not a drug
if I sell a soap and I tell you that
this soap is really good for acne
I am crossing a line so even if I
formulate it maybe it's a high coconut
oil soap so it's high in cleansing if I
promise that it's going to do something
I fall under the Food and Drug
Administration and have to have my
product tested and whatever it takes to
be approved
um there are other examples are
antibacterial cleansers and then they
use talk about the ones but you know a
lot of people a lot of the our soaps are
good for people with psoriasis and other
skin conditions but as soon as you start
talking about that you're a drug
so everything I talk about today I'm
going to talk about is going to be based
on what the federal drug and cosmetic
act talks about so there's two things
that they really talk about is you must
sell a product that's not adulterated
or misbranded
and that's what I'm going to talk about
because what I did then is developed my
good manual good manufacturing practices
so that
I can meet these two answers
or um
things you have to meet
all right so here's the first goal I'm
going to create manufacturing and
testing protocols
I'm going to establish GMP to reduce the
risk and the documentation that you can
use for this also is ones from the
federal government that basically
exactly tells you what's in their
regulation and then Marie Gale also puts
out a book that is specifically
directed towards GMP for soap makers and
cosmetic makers
so it's very good for us
just to give you an idea these are all
the sections
GMP is big and it gets real detailed and
my goal was not to add all of this
administrative work to make my job
harder my goal was to make my product
better and so that everything I do I did
to create accountability for me so that
my customers could could have that sense
of
that they knew what they were going to
get every time so I don't look at it as
a
a Bad Thing even though it's a lot of
Regulation or a lot of documentation
because it's going to mean a better
product and accountability for me just
you know GMP is not regulations it is
practices it is not enforceable there is
no audit from anybody the Cosmetics I
believe the government wants you to
register
it is optional
and so I haven't done it and probably
won't because I'm not sure what benefit
it would give me
but uh
it is just a practice
it is Big you can tell from that
previous slide so what you want to do is
start with the biggest or the easiest
areas that have the most risk
to make mistakes
all right so now we're going to start
talking about
the different parts of GMP so the
easiest place most times to start is
with your master formula so this is
basically your recipe with enough detail
that you will find when you follow it
you will get the same results every time
and without it you can't guarantee that
to your customers with it you already
know of the base that you can create a
consistent product
a couple of things that contains the
ingredients in the quantity detailed
steps but not just do this do this do
this but it also includes you know what
temperature should the ingredients be at
that step or how do you know when mixing
is complete what Trace looks like or a
thin trace or a thick Trace
also details for quality control what
does it look like what does it smell
like how thick should it be when it
comes to cream soap those types of
things
you know you have the right amount of
detail when
a person that's reasonably familiar with
similar projects products can follow
your master formula so that was the
hardest thing because the examples they
go way way deep so remember my goal was
not to create this administrative
nightmare so that was one of the hard
things was to find a level of detail
that was correct the second thing is the
batch record
so it is documenting that you are
following your master formulation the
easiest thing you can do is kind of
start with your master recipe and then
create checkbox that's the easiest way
to move from that to that
includes the date made who made it how
many units and also a batch record or
batch log number
all right so that's the recipe now
um
this came second for me but really in
the process it happens before you make
your recipe is your ingredients back
so if your ingredients are not
consistent from batch to batch you can't
even if you follow the same recipe you
may get different results
so this part is establishing standard
criterias for your ingredients and for
your materials
then you're also going to look at your
suppliers and who will supply them to
meet your specifications
and then as you go through your master
record then you'll verify the
ingredients before using them
one thing I learned is that you want to
have two vendors for each of your
ingredients or materials because what if
they run out and you need to get some
made or what if they quit selling your
product and I you know you've all had
that where they're back ordered and
you're struggling to all of a sudden
find it the one thing I ran into was I
used a lot of Malibu bottles for my
lotion and I have yet to find a
substitute
supplier that I probably should have
never started I should have picked
something out and I'm using another
bottle I don't like it as well
that's the way this all right so so far
this is everything we've talked about
you need a Master Formula batch record a
bachelor of material specs inventory log
and inventory batch record so that seems
like a lot of information
so let's take a second look at it
so this is then how it starts right so
before I can order ingredients I have to
set my specs this is my example of what
I use for my material specs I probably
have a sheet of paper that has four of
these on a page so that I can cut them
up and I will have them posted on my
racks so that when I look at them I have
in front of me my shelf life
when I and it also tells me who I will
order them from
it also has the scientific name and
we'll talk a little bit about that in
the end why it's important
um
here cocoa butter Raw
when you go to order if you don't have
this now what did I use in that last
recipe was it raw or refined
because there's a difference in color
and there's a difference in odor and
there's a difference in texture
so when you go order it that's when
these things become important
when that ingredient then gets shipped
to you you come in and you have your
incoming raw material lock
so there you're going to write your Lot
number and what I do for lot number is I
use a system where the first two numbers
are the year that I received it in so
I'll have 15 Dash and then I'll have
zero zero one and I'll go through and
that's my Lot number when I received it
the name the quantity in those things
expiration date which is really cool
because I have it on the specs so I know
where that to find that information
and then a little bit of the other
information there is a final column that
says accept doesn't meet the
specifications and that's real easy
again you have them right there in front
of you you know how it should look and
you should know how it should smell
um
an example of one that you don't think
of maybe is like tubes where the lids
don't fit on type like lip balm tubes or
I had a batch of bottles where the
little plastic had a little catch on all
of them I mean those are the kinds of
things that you start to notice when you
are actually inspecting things as they
come in
after I um right on my log then I also
create a label for the product that I
have fixed to it and that just is real
simple it has product name Lot number
and expiration date and that way when I
pick something up because one of it was
to verify it when you use it in your in
your rest in your recipe right and so
there is a quick way to verify the
expiration date
uh just so you know when I started this
one of the things I did do was an
inventory of my um
uh ingredients and anything that I
couldn't go back that year to find the
the invoice for and I knew some of it
was older than a year those special
ingredients you got the try once
and I threw out because I couldn't
validate that and so I said I'm gonna do
it right gonna have that consistent
product so there was ingredients I threw
out at the beginning of the process
here's an example of my master batch
recipe so it's kind of like the bottom
part of my cream soap recipe and then it
has the directions
and
um
I include the ingredients how much of it
and also then I include the NC name
because I want those so accessible when
it comes to writing labels that I just
make it part of everything
and then those are the directions so
yeah so now you can see
you know I weigh the coconut oil and add
it to the slow cooker I weigh the
sunflower oil and add it to the slow
cooker they're pretty detailed
possibly you could say add your soft
oils add your hard oils you know you
would have to really think about that
um
however like number 13 just to point out
it's like pour the lies into the water
under the stove vent on high so I think
that's good because
um you do and I also talk about Sir and
it isn't you know it's dirt until it's
dissolved and water is clear so that's
an example of not only
you know mix the two but what it should
look like afterwards
to me this is the best part that I've
really loved is the batch log it has
product number and I'll talk about how I
come up with my product number in the
next slide prac name date here's my
batch number
so the first thing that this does is
when you start the next batch you go to
the batch log to find out what batch
number you're starting with next so
that's the big thing I use my batch log
but I say okay which soaps are done
curing I go to my bachelor I say okay
these and I'm ready to be done curing I
didn't talk about that but you would
also have a master recipe for how to
package your soaps so it isn't just for
the manufacturing side but it's also for
the packaging side and how you get them
out the door
um
you think the cream soaps are probably
harder because how am I going to get
them in my jars so they might feel like
a little bit more then it talks about
how many units so if I make
a log of soap at 16 bars at four and a
half ounces each and so that's why I'll
fill in so product number you
come up with your own way this is what I
do I have the first two letters talk
about what kind of product it is so my
CS is cream soap my LS is liquid soap my
BS is bath soap or bar soap
then my middle one
the next segment we'll talk about what
recipe it is so under ls-form one that
is my form my first recipe if I have
more liquid soaps I'll add form too
um
the bath soap you can see there I have a
swirl recipe that's a little bit slower
moving for me facial soap will have
more gentle ingredients and so it's
formulated different so I will
um that tells me what recipe I'm using
and then the last segment will tell me
fragrance
um
there
because I also and I'm trying to do this
better I don't buy a lot of different
colors when I make soap I try and buy my
primary colors and mix them well if I
want to get the same purple now I'm
going to have to start documenting so
that'll come into play even when I do
that or how much fragrance this kind of
soap gets over this kind of soap that
all comes into play and that's why it's
important to have them for that so on
that batch log then that's my product ID
will have my bs-sw Dash
whatever
all right so now I'm ready to make soap
finally and so now I'm going to follow
my batch record so it's similar to the
master record except you can check
things off except there's a few other
things to point out
at the top
you have your product ID
so I have that you also have your batch
number
so those are the two things that this
will identify this batch of soap and
then you also have your date and I put a
start time and the end time because I
want to know how much my soap is costing
me to make so that helps me with my
labor
when I do my costing I will start and
end time for manufacturing certain end
time for Packaging and so I get a true
cost of my labor
and then I'll have the grams listed and
then I will also document the actual
amount used and again this is because
what is my standard operating procedure
going to say if I get a little bit too
much is that okay
is five percent over okay as one percent
over okay or one percent under okay I
mean what what is my variance level that
I'm okay with
um because I don't always pour straight
and then as soon as I do that then I
create a little tag that has the product
name the batch number the manufacturing
date and that goes with first with the
log and then after I cut it it goes with
that and that's how it's identified on
the shelves
I didn't say that when I create that tag
for the ingredients a lot of times you I
have to put um packaging tape over it
because I'm telling you there is not a
whole lot of inks that can hold up to
oils and so that helps
all right then standard operating
procedures so these are the ones with
the most words I think and the harder
because you just do it
or you don't do it and you should be
doing it so the good thing about
standard operating procedures is it
makes you question your your how you do
things so I have a scale
is it accurate
how are you going to know
how often should you test it to make
sure it's accurate
is there a right answer
the right answer is whatever you put in
your standard operating procedures and
there probably is a little bit for some
of them
a little bit better the calibrate your
pH I think meter is supposed to be every
month
um but there are other things safety
precautions look at I have wild hair
do I need to wear a hair net
you know all of those things I have a
workshop my husband walks by my workshop
and wants to come in do I let him in
after he's been out in the goat Barn you
know it's some of that stuff which he
doesn't like it when I think like that
and I kick him out
um
the other thing we didn't talk about is
10 minutes okay
um is how I how do you handle complaints
so there's another
possibly log that you can create but
afterwards it's really hard because it's
the emotional thing do it ahead of time
it's not so bad
all right
and these are examples just of other
things
um
that you can talk about I guess I didn't
show you on that other screen there was
a link um Marie Gayle also has
um a good book on standard operating
procedures
oh there it is
so um oh we're going to talk about
labeling
yeah so that was the other part for
Cosmetics you have to have unadulterated
product and you have to have good
labeling so we're going to talk about
that next
and they have different rules for your
front panel which is what the the
customers are most likely to read and
the other panels which are called
information panels
and on the front panel
you have to have your name your identity
and your your contents your contents
must be in both metric and in US
measurements
you have to identify is it soap or is it
whatever else is it
and also then this is the part that I
put up with from the government then is
then that your texts they get very
specific and it needs to be an eighth of
an inch high based on the letter
lowercase o Place bottom parallel in the
bottom thirty percent of your label
um these things
they will say good practice is even if
you're selling soap to have this much
okay
um again those soap is not regulated
the information panels the back or side
panels and that's what they say if
you're selling soap you at least want to
have your name and address
oh did I
okay
um
directions for safe use and you have to
have your ingredients and warning
statements so let's take a look at a
couple of those your name and address I
live on the farm do I really want my
Farm address on my label
the answer is no but you will
the uh now the the caveat is is if
you're listed in a printed phone book
you don't have to
so I may look at that I do have people
that drive up in my yard and oh we just
stopped to see your
your uh
thing and that's okay but I would prefer
a phone call
um
can I use a post office box and the
answer is no
um right now the h
scg handcrafters handcrafted soap
cosmetic Guild is putting together a
petition to take to allow PO Boxes but
right now you cannot use them it has to
be your physical location
ingredients you need to use the NC name
which is from the Cosmetic ingredient
dictionary except your Botanical
ingredients you use their common name
so
you list them in order the ingredient
that there's the most stuff is first
and then you go down
if you buy any type of a base or a blend
you have to list those ingredients
individually too with respect to your
soap so you can't just add I don't buy
any base Blends or bases so I'm not sure
what you have but you have to split them
out well uh
I used to do a lotion base that I would
buy so I can't just say lotion base I
would have to list in any ingredients I
have a really good recipe now
um ingredients a couple more things
fragrance you can list as a ketchall you
don't have to break it free so a lot of
us like to say that we're phthalate free
or paraben free or all those things
um
they don't have to list it other
products don't have to list it because
of this and you can just list fragrance
ingredients that are less than one
percent you don't have to worry about
the amount
there any order is fine color additives
there is a list of approved color
additives and you have to abide by that
but you can list them all last
no matter if they're above that one
percent or above that other
so those are always last
after all the other ingredients
so some of you use essential oils so do
and you'd like to probably say hey I use
lemongrass essential oil what if you use
lemongrass and tea tree
so if you want to list that you are
using a lemongrass essential oil and you
also have something else you have to
list all of them you can't you know if
it's a proprietary blend and you want
only want to list a couple of them nope
you have to list all of the essential
oils if you don't want to do that then
you have to list it as fragrance and
then you don't have to give out your
proprietary blend
there are some special rules about
um
Trade Secrets and those I don't know nor
did I include them so
um so that kind of is the end of my
presentation was there any questions for
me so the question was is how many goats
do you need to um before to make your to
make it worthwhile
so what um for a bar of soap I say that
one-fourth of your bar is goat's milk
so if I make a four ounce bar I need one
ounce of goat's milk so in a gallon of
goat
milk I get 128 ounces so that can make
me 128 bars from that one gallon of
goat's milk
so if you're making milking a goat and
they're giving you a gallon of milk a
day
you're making a lot of soap every day
so one goat for you to start we'll do it
and I only have a handful of goats that
I milk I don't the rest are meat crusts
or meat commercial Meats
foreign